in terms of the major religions of the
world we all know about Christianity and
Islam Hinduism and Buddhism these are
Traditions that have shaped our world to
significant degrees and which still have
billions of followers worldwide but one
religion that isn't as large today but
might still represent one of the most
influential and important religious
traditions in history is
Zoroastrianism being associated Prim
arily with Iran and Central Asia and
serving essentially as the state
religion for some of the great Persian
Empires zor asianism also probably had a
major influence on certain key features
of the abrahamic faiths many have of
course heard about zor asianism but
knowledge about the details of this
religion is often very limited and
shallow uh people will maybe know that
this is the religion that Freddy Mercury
belonged to or that it is a religion
that has an essentially dualistic world
world view uh concerned with the fight
of of good against evil light against
Darkness this is all true but there's so
much of Zoran ISM that most people
aren't aware of a long history of
development with unique teachings that
have of course evolved and changed over
the centuries and Millennia but the core
of which stretches back far into
Antiquity to some of the earliest
religious literature in the history of
the world so in this episode let's spend
some time
and dive deep into the fascinating and
very important religion of
[Applause]
Zoroastrianism veteran viewers will
perhaps be aware that I've already made
an episode like this about zor aism way
back in the very early days of this
Channel and while there's not
necessarily anything wrong about that
episode or anything that I think is is
you know bad that I would change
necessarily as such um the production
value of this channnel the videos here
has significantly increased and gotten
better since then and I feel like an
important topic like zor aism deserves a
video that is uh more pleasing to look
at and listen
to uh you know couple that with the fact
that both uh research on this topic
generally and my own knowledge of this
subject has also significantly increased
and and and developed over the years
since that video so for both of these
reasons I felt that it was uh necessary
that it was uh appropriate to do a
another video about zor rism that goes
even deeper and takes into account all
these uh nuances and and new
understandings and more complex aspects
of its history development and teachings
Zoroastrianism is a very old religion in
terms of an organized religion so to say
it could be considered one of the oldest
in the world and many indeed consider it
the first monotheistic religion in
history there are caveats to this
especially the latter statement as we
will see but for sure it is a tradition
that stretches back very far into the
past but for this reason it has of
course evolved and changed over the
Millennia too giving rise to different
and sometimes competing interpretations
of its theology literature and
practices most of the text of the Zoran
religion was written down or codified
for the first time during the cenan
empire around the middle of the first
Millennium ad or CE although these texts
had been orally transmitted for a long
time before that it is also around this
time probably in relation to this that
some of the core characteristics of the
religion's teachings that we are
familiar with became more formally
organized and established a kind of
quote unquote Orthodoxy if you will what
I mean to point out with this is that
our common understanding of Zoran belief
and practice is often primarily based on
these developments during the cenan
Empire the the codified and and sort of
official teachings that were set down at
this particular period in time thus the
teachings that had been established by
then is the lens through which much
older texts and aspects of the religion
such as the Goths are interpreted by
most people in any case the basic
features of Zoran ISM as most people
know it is that there is some kind of
combination between a monotheistic Faith
with a dualistic cosmology the world
viiew of zor asianism is that of a clear
cosmologic iCal dualism between the
forces of Good and Evil between light
and darkness often represented by the
forces of Aura Mazda on the one hand and
angra minu on the other or between Asha
and duj we'll return to these terms and
Concepts later but this also means that
Zoran ism is a heavily ethical religion
concerned with the individual's ethical
actions in this world so living
according to the principles of good
thoughts good words and Good Deeds to
promote the forces of Asha of order and
goodness in the the world and also
promising an afterlife of pleasure or
punishment depending on how the person
acted during their lifetime these
characteristics of the religion are
largely true although some may need to
be nuanced a little bit but we need to
go a little deeper and from different
perspectives to get a proper
understanding of the complexities of
this tradition I think it might serve as
well to as we often do do this in a
chronological order so with that said
what is the origins or early development
ments of zor asianism well at the core
of zorran ritual and belief are a set of
writings a group of poems or songs
called The
Goth this for all intents and purposes
is considered the oldest source and
beginning of Zoran ISM in some way the
goth serve as the basis for much of the
core teachings of the religion and as an
important part of ritual and practical
life for zor Asians to this day The Goth
are ascribed to an ancient figure called
zarathustra sometimes referred to in
Greek as
zoroaster a poet and Sage who is
considered the original founder quot of
zor
asianism depending on who you ask
zarathustra is described as a prophet a
poet Sage a philosopher or perhaps all
of the above but all agree that if he is
a historical person he is indeed a core
figure for the formation and origins of
the religion Scholars both within and
out side the zoroastrian tradition
greatly disagree on dating the life of
zarathustra and the goas some placing
him at a very early date around the
middle of the second millennium BC While
others plac his life in the middle of
the first millennium BC so around the
year 500 BC or so at the very early days
of the acced Empire based on the
linguistic features of the Goths
themselves the majority of Scholars
today I would say and I do tend to agree
with them favors the earlier date thus
placing the life of zarra sometime
around the year 1500 BC give or take
this makes his poems or songs The Goth
roughly contemporary with the
composition of the rveda in The Vedic
culture in India making it some of the
oldest religious and philosophical
literature in the history of the world
and indeed this connection is important
in other ways too because the context of
early zor asianism is very much
connected to the viic culture in India
the Indo Arian language group that
migrated into Northern India which
became Central to the formation of quot
unquote Hinduism or the viic culture and
the Proto Iranians that migrated to the
West share a common origin both
linguistically and culturally you could
say and we can see this in the
similarity of many terms and Concepts
shared between zor asianism and indic
religion such as words like dvas Ashura
versus Aura H and Som Etc so we should
imagine zarathustra growing up and
living in in a society not unlike that
of the viic culture in India and when we
read The Goth for instance I think it's
much more fruitful to do that through
this particular lens rather than reading
it through more of an abrahamic lens
that I think a lot of people tend to do
today while we aren't sure about much of
zarra's life at all all we have to go on
are the many later Legends as well as
Clues and their goth as themselves it's
widely argued that he was from what is
today Northeastern Iran the goas are Po
in a language referred to as old a
veston and the poems uses imagery and
metaphors that point to a society of
mobile pastoralism as there are many
references to horses and livestock
including the important notion of the
so-called soul of the cow as some kind
of cosmic concept the soul of the cow in
the goth represents the soul of the
world in some way and zarathustra talks
about the shepherd as an ideal person
that takes care of the livestock and in
a similar way the good person is someone
that takes care of the soul of the cow
that is nature itself and the World At
Large as a Shepherd would take care of
his animals so sarra figured in a mobile
pastoral Society with a religious
tradition that was probably strongly
related to the vidic one with a heavy
focus on ritual and probably things like
sacrifices and offerings and an
essentially polytheistic theology with
many different gods or deities indeed it
seems that this culture shared certain
Gods with its neighbors in India such as
Indra and Vu among others although it's
also interesting to consider that the
terms for the gods are sort of reversed
so the good gods in India in the India
context are referred to as the dvas
whereas the auras are the bad gods in
the Iranian context it's it's reversed
so here the auras are the good Gods
whereas the Davis as we will see are a
term that refers to evil spirits or evil
Gods so in that way they're reversed but
we can see still that this religious
tradition was sh share they they share a
common ancestry a common origin and are
very much like each other later legends
about zarathustra tell how he was a
priest of this older religion thus he
would have been in charge of Performing
rights and other related things but as
he traveled around the region he was
struck by the violence and unethical
behavior of many of the people something
was wrong but he wasn't quite sure what
it was or how to solve it this is one of
the key themes that we find in the Goths
when we read these texts are attributed
to SRA that is very much concerned with
with with ethics and pointing out how
leaders and people around the world what
was his world which was you know Iran at
that time uh were sort of corrupted and
evil and egotistical you know violent
all these things this a very common
theme in these texts but then something
very dramatic happened which would
change his life and if it is a
historical event changed the course of
the
world
[Music]
it is s that during a Spring Festival
where he might have been working in His
function as priest he went down to the
river to fetch some
water but as he was stepping out of the
water he suddenly had an intense vision
of light then a shining being referred
to as vhum good purpose spoke to him
zarathustra was given a kind of
Revelation with the truths about reality
and its working was revealed to him just
as they
are and at the center of this Revelation
was a quite radical concept rather than
the more polytheistic religion than he
was taught in it was revealed to him
that there is only one creative absolute
force and Source in reality called Aura
Mazda Aura Mazda is often translated as
the wise Lord or the Lord of wisdom and
represents one of the key Concepts in
zor
arism Aura Mazda later often written as
oraz is the creative force behind all
existence at least everything good and
harmonious in the world especially later
Aura Mazda is often seen as somewhat
equivalent to the monotheistic God the
sole Creator and sustainer of the world
but it isn't entirely clear just how it
should be conceived in these earliest
sources some translators and Scholars
today favoring more quote unquote
philosophical interpretation of the
Goths and the teachings of zarathustra
such as Ash dalan who recently published
a translation of the goas into Swedish
choose to translate auram Asda as
something like the high wisdom thus
giving it a more abstract philosophical
ring compared to the more theological
interpretations of aamas as a God in the
more conventional sense that seem to
have become the norm later on whether or
not this story about zarra's Revelation
on the riverbank is historically true
true or not it serves as a popular
legend about his life that also
legitimizes his role as a kind of
enlightened Sage but Scholars are unsure
of just how to categorize
zarathustra it used to be popular to
refer to him as a prophet thus the
prophet of zor aism similar to um
Muhammad being the prophet and founder
of Islam indeed many Muslim scholars in
history also chose to look at
zarathustra precisely as one of the many
prophets sent by God mentioned in the
Quran also thus legitimizing placing
these orasan under the category of the
people of the book and it's still
popular today to talk about him in such
a way but this might be a bit
anachronistic in a way reading his life
through an abrahamic lens so to say
perhaps he can better be compared to the
rishis or sages of ancient India that
originated the vadas some as we saw also
choose to categorize him as a
philosopher and this can have a
significant impact on how we read the
Goths I think what we can be most safe
in claiming is that he was a a poet or a
singer maybe after all the one direct
probably direct source that we have of
him is the goth themselves a collection
of poem songs so clearly he was some
kind of sage poet blessed with unique
insight into the workings of reality in
the universe there is a term in olda
veston which is used self-referentially
in the gothis themselves called a mantan
this means something like a person that
uses words like poetry to convey deep
existential truth with Clarity I think
this if anything is perhaps what we can
most surely ascribe to
zarathustra not least because it is a
term that he seemingly uses for himself
too the Insight that Zara was given
about reality whether through the famous
story at the river bank or not is what
he expresses in the Goths and which
serves as some of the most key aspects
of zor asrian thought and belief The
Goth also serve as the core of the wider
Corpus of zor asan Sacred Scriptures
known as the aesta which aside from the
Goths include many other texts such as
the Yash or hymns to Divine Powers the
vendidad the visper among many other
texts and these texts are all written in
a language group or groups known as old
aveston which is from roughly 1500 to
1,000 BC and young aveston which is from
1,000 BC to around 500 BC in general
these zor scriptures are very varied and
new ones appeared as late as the Islamic
period around the 8th to 9th centuries
ad but the avesta the oldest and most
important collection of Sacred
Scriptures which includes the Goths make
up what we could consider the the the
core of the tradition and it was only
transmitted orally until the first few
centuries ad while we should remember
that zor asianism just like any religion
is a tradition that changed and evolved
over the centuries and millennia so the
religion practiced by Darius the ained
emperor uh was quite different in many
ways from the religion uh practiced by
the cenan empires a few centuries later
still if we look at these oldest sources
in these texts we might be able to
reconstruct a kind of a core uh set of
teachings and characteristics that are
true for the most part at least across
the board uh for most of zorian History
so with this in mind what can we say
about the teachings of zor arism I think
we can begin by looking at the
scriptures themselves in fact the very
opening of the first gotha or song
ascribed to zarathustra where he says
quote in reverence for him with hands
outstretched at first I entreat you all
oh Aura Mazda for the actions of support
of the spirit holy through truth or Asha
through whom you may gratify the
intellect of good thought and the soul
of the cow I approach you with good
thought oh Mazda Aura so that you may
grant me the blessings of the two
existences the material and that of
thought the blessings emanating from
truth with which you can put your
supporters in Comfort I extol you as
ever before Oh truth Asha and good
thought bhana and Mazda Aura for all of
whom right-mindedness increases also
unfading power may you come to my cause
for support inspired by good thoughts
and being a witness for Mazda aura I
have in mind one soul for his
Commendation by my song as well as the
rewards for his actions for as long as I
can and I able I shall look out in my
search for truth already in this opening
of the goas recited as a key part of the
Zoran liturgy or yasna we already have
some Clues to the key teachings of the
religion first of all there is only one
creative force or God in reality Aura
Mazda the Lord of wisdom who is called
upon call constantly in the text he's
the source of all good all light all
creation and
wisdom this is why many have referred to
zor aism as essentially monotheistic or
even the first monotheistic religion in
the world but things are also a lot more
complicated than that as we will see
secondly what lies at the very core of
these orasan scriptures and teachings is
essentially an ethical message this is
the key message that is hammered home
again and again
humans have free will and there is a
very clear idea of right and wrong of
Good and Evil indeed inherent in this
ethical message is a very strong
dualism this is not the mindbody dualism
of decart or the horizontal dualism of
certain strands of platonism or say
Christianity but rather a vertical
dualism all of created reality is
divided into truth and falsehood into
right and wrong lights and darkness both
of the Two Worlds mentioned in the quote
above that of material and that of
thought are included in this dualism so
it's not a matter versus Spirit
situation as in Christianity for example
on the one side there is Asha a concept
meaning truth or that which is right
real or things like order and Harmony
this can be compared to the evic idea of
or perhaps even Maat in ancient Egyptian
religion the creation of Aura Mazda is
essentially good beautiful and
harmonious it is perfect because Aura
Mazda himself is perfect and good Asha
or truth is the principle of that
goodness and order in the world the way
things are supposed to be according to
the wisdom of Aura
ma but on the other side of the coin
there is also duj which means the lie or
deception this is the very opposite of
Asha and it is conceived at least in
later oror astranis as is a force that
has been introduced to the perfect
creation of ahur Mazda from the outside
so to say and the human being and all of
creation is caught in this place that
contains both good the domain of ahur
MAA and Asha and evil that of du and its
forces so our world of creation contains
both good and evil at least in this
current state these forces or concepts
are often also personified in different
ways especially as we get into the
younger aesta and later zor asrian WR
ings in the Goths themselves it isn't
always entirely clear how we should
think of these Concepts some readings by
Scholars such as John Kellin and the
aforementioned Ash dalan see much of
these things as simply uh psychological
and internal Concepts and workings
within the human person the creation of
auram Mazda is essentially good in its
totality but within the human soul there
exist inclinations in two directions on
the one hand there is spenta minu often
translated as beneficient inspiration or
beneficient Spirit which leads you to
work for the benefit of Asha and
goodness and almost as a kind of Faculty
of Aura Mazda and on the other hand
there is angra minu the destructive
spirit that inclines to evil deception
and
destruction however this oldest text
should be interpreted later zoroastrian
writings and teachings have a more
cosmological perspective on this dualism
Aura Mazda is the one creat god of the
cosmos whose creation is perfect and
good and angrau becomes a kind of
personified Spirit himself as the
opposite of Aura Mazda the force in
reality that has infiltrated the perfect
creation of Aura Mazda to spread duj
lies and deception things like violence
death and
Decay so the world we live in today is
one in which both of these forces Asha
and D represented to some degree by
ahura Mazda and angrau respectively are
work
simultaneously and it is our work our
job as human beings to choose the path
of Asha of Truth and Order and to dispel
the darkness of drj from the
world in the goth zarathustra talks a
lot about the shepherd as a kind of
Ideal person one who takes care of the
livestock and of nature as the image of
the person who follows the path of
Asha this he compares to people who
instead are misled by the Davis the evil
gods or deities to seek power money or
destroy the world in different ways
through violence so you see what I mean
when I say that the zor asrian message
is an essentially ethical one this fight
between good and evil between truth and
deception Asha and Dr is the very core
of the religion and the avestan
scriptures and the human being promotes
Asha partly through performing the
zorran rituals of course such as the
yasna Liturgy or the daily prayers Etc
but on a more personal practical level
this is done by adhering to the main you
could say the main Mantra or instruction
that people are to follow humata H vesa
which means good thoughts good words and
Good
Deeds this a pretty neat and simple
instruction but this also of course
requires knowing what makes up Good
Deeds for instance by being able to
identify which aspects of the world are
part of the good creation of ahor MAA
and which are the result of angra minu
so there are certain things in the world
that are seen as pure and sacred such as
fire and running water that must not be
defiled in any way at the same time
there are certain things in the world
like some animals seen as impure or evil
this includes snakes and frogs and
things like this and it is sort of um
encouraged that you are supposed to kill
these animals of evil to promote Asha in
the world the goal of the zor asran is
thus to live his or her life in
accordance with Asha or truth to devote
themselves to Aur Mazda the Lord of
wisdom or high wisdom and to worship Him
and the goodness that he represents in
thought speech and action the person who
has accomplished this who adheres to
Asha in their life is known as an ashaan
thus representing this ultimate goal of
the human being this stands in contrast
to the dregant the follower of duj who
spreads evil and falsehood in the world
in the gotha sarus just say quote I
replied firstly I am zarathustra a
veritable opponent of the evildoer but a
powerful friend of the good am I so long
as I can sing my songs of praise for
thee Oh Mazda so long shall I strive to
Enlighten and awaken all to the
realization of thy Eternal dominion and
this also figures into the large
cosmogonical and eschatological picture
as well especially if we take into
account later Zoran writings too such as
the important and fascinating vibod
this is a young aveston text from well
again from around 1100 to 500 BC here
there's a clear account of sacred
history that is presented it begins with
the creation of the World by aoda Mazda
as a perfect creation this uh wonderful
situation lasts for a while often
sometimes considered 6,000 years before
the evil spirits angrau I sort of
infiltrates or infects this perfect
world spreading du and creating the
situation that we have now a world of
both good and evil this fight between
good and evil continues but reaches a
kind of Turning Point with the life and
you could say mission of zarathustra
himself and the establishment of zor
asan rituals and worldview that sort of
starts the process of asha's victory
over duj the gradual victory of light
over darkness in the end and connected
with the arrival of a savior figure
called the seant the world will be
revitalized at last an event or concept
called
Fresh this word is connected as you can
probably hear with the English word
fresh and we can thus kind of imagine it
as the world becoming fresh again the
darkness of angru and duj finally being
dispelled and the creation of Aura Mazda
once again being able to be what it was
from the beginning a perfect world of
Harmony and order at this juncture the
zoroastrian scriptures also Imagine
because of its strong the ethical nature
of of course that the individual human
being will also face a kind of
Retribution here after the world is
redeemed every human being will be
judged based on their actions in life
this was quite unique at this time the
idea that our ethical actions effect our
afterlife directly rather than things
like status or other features that were
more common in other Traditions so
including the ancient Iranian religion
the ashaan the person who has followed
and promoted Asha in their life will
live a pleasant life in the company of a
hura Mazda in this perfect world whereas
the dregant who promoted deception and
evil in the world he will be punished
and face a very unpleasant afterlife in
a place called The House of
Lies it is taught that at this point the
dead person will be forced to walk
across a bridge on the other side is
Paradise for all intents and purposes
but on the bottom below the bridge is
the House of Lies what can essentially
be considered hell for the Shan or
righteous person this bridge will be
very wide and easy to cross but for a
quote unquote bad person the bridge will
contract to be as thin as the edge of a
blade making it almost impossible to
cross and causing the person to
basically inevitably fall down into
Eternal punishment zarra says quote the
kpan priests and the kavis so worldly
leaders have terized over Humanity their
evil actions are destructive of Life
verily the conscience of such a one
shall torment his soul and thus when
they shall come to the bridge of
judgment their Abode for Endless ages
shall be in the house of the lie for
those of you that are familiar with the
abrahamic faiths a lot of this will of
course feel right at home because these
features are basically identical to
certain eschatological beliefs in
religions like particularly in in Islam
and Christianity and we'll return to
these similarities and possible
connections later on in the episode 2 at
this point I think it is also worthwhile
to discuss more in detail the theology
at play here because it can be a little
complicated like we said Zoroastrianism
is often called the first monotheistic
religion in the world and this isn't
without reason indeed as we saw the goth
and avestan scriptures consider Aura
Mazda to be the one creator of the world
as far as we consider a god with a
capital G azda is it and No One Compares
with him but things are aren't really
this simple and neat especially if we
try to look at it and Define monotheism
through the lens of the abrahamic
religions and the kind of monotheism
that we find in say Judaism or Islam
first of all we have already been
introduced to the concept of angru the
evil spirit that stands on the you could
say the opposite end of auraa is a kind
of spirit of darkness and evil doesn't
this kind of paint the picture of two
Gods with opposing
qualities the relationship between
angrau and Aura Mazda changed according
to different theologies and developments
across the centuries and Millennia and
sometimes they do indeed seem to be
equal in some way such as with the
so-called zanite movement during the
cenan Empire when the two basically
became seen as two sons of an even
higher Divine figure called zurvan or
time on the other hand in the Goths
themselves one could interpret it in a
very different way where auram Mazda is
the one God and angamu is only a
personification of some other for force
that exists in creation either
ontologically or simply in the human
psyche secondly and this is even more
confusing to some while auram Mazda is
the one Creator God and the highest Lord
in reality on his side we also find
other Divine forces or concepts such as
the amas spentas and the yazatas
the amesa spentas the holy Immortals is
a concept that we find already in the
Goths themselves even though this term
isn't used there and here the here as
certain you could say attributes or
manifestations perhaps to use
philosophical language you see them as
emanations of auram Masta that are
manifested in the world and in human
actions in different ways the scholar
Jenny Rose says quote The Goth
introduced the notion that the ashaan
should further certain qualities besides
Asha that are associated with promoting
the best existence this leads to the
consideration that these may be separate
entities which along with other abstract
forces found in the Goths form part of a
complex web of inter relationships with
aura Mazda so these amas spentas are
qualities of Aura Mazda that should be
embodied by the person as part of that
goodness and wisdom that make up God and
His
Creation in the Goths there is no set
number for the sesa spentas but in later
writings they're defined as seven Asha
or truth is one of them as is spent minu
which we mentioned earlier this is
translated as beneficient inspiration or
beneficient Spirit there is vhana good
thought or good purpose there isra
Dominion arti holy devotion or love
there's harvat wholeness or Perfection
and Amat or immortality while in the
gothest themselves these can be read as
emanations or aspects of a hurda in some
way in later Peri periods they often
became seen as figures or Spirits in
themselves spenta minu was usually
identified outright with azda himself
whereas the rest were often individual
Divine entities that were also often the
object of worship in different ways each
of them would also be associated with
certain aspects of the natural world or
other abstract Concepts so that um Asha
for instance was associated with fire
and Devotion to this amas spenta Asha
was through fire so to say this can be a
pretty complicated idea and definitely
complicates the theology especially if
we're looking for a more strict
monotheism in the abrahamic sense and
furthermore these amas spentas and even
auram Masta himself was also seen as
part of a wider group of beings called
the yazatas which literally means those
worthy of worship the yazatas are Divine
beings that can be worshiped and also
include other popular Divine entities
such as as Mithra and anahita among
others so what's going on here if there
are multiple gods that are worshiped
what role does auna Mazda actually play
and can we then actually call this a
monotheism well this is pretty
complicated as you can see I'm usually
careful to use terms like monotheism
because it can become quite
anachronistic to use it in this way and
thus project certain expectations from a
completely different context onto
something that really doesn't fit for
sure the azadas were the object of
worship for zor asrian throughout
history but not everyone wants to call
them Gods necessarily some have referred
to them as something akin to angels in
the abrahamic situation indeed the term
Yaz seems to be used for a wide array of
different things such as um everything
from healing plans to fravashi 2 this a
concept that we'll return to later so
yazatas can mean a broader category of
things that are worthy of worship which
can include um natural things but also
the mesas spentas and it can also
sometimes even include Aura Masta
himself although he is usually sort of
considered as above or Transcendent of
all these other categories some might
perhaps be tempted to use a term like
henotheism to describe it where um
multiple gods are recognized as existing
but only one God being exalted and
worshiped as the sort of highest God in
existence but again I think this is a
sort of anachronistic way of looking at
it it's trying to to fit something into
our preconceived categories and boxes
whereas this
is it's more complicated than that right
this is a completely different u Way of
of looking at the relationship between
these different Divine beings and how
the cosmos functions in that way I think
uh while it can be helpful to use these
terms and to discuss them like we are
now monotheism or henotheism or whatever
you want to have it um I think at the
end of the day the best way to do this
is simply to look at it for what it is
right we look at this as a unique case
in itself uh the zoroastrian theology is
unique right they have this high God
this um somewhat monotheistic idea right
that is the one God but there are other
Divine beings too and it's not like Aura
Mazda is one among the same category of
divine beings and that he is just
exalted about the other as in other
henotheism perhaps um ahda seems to be
in sort of a category of his own
completely he is he is god with a
capital G whereas the others are Divine
beings maybe not even Gods some many
people not even want to call them gods
they call them Angels or simply
uh Divine beings or in the case of
Scholars and in many textbooks they will
just use the the aest term yadas which I
think is pretty wise right because it it
it avoids many of these problems that we
run into um by using terms like gods or
deities uh so maybe we should do that
too simply call them for what they are
which is the azadas and aaza is his sort
of own category I don't know it's it's a
complicated situation but I think that's
worth um keeping in mind all these
aspects and things when we discuss this
topic like I said the azadas including
the amas spentas are an integral part of
the religion since the earliest period
and significantly nuances our
understanding and reminds us not to
oversimplify based on our preconceived
categories it should be pointed out also
that some have argued that the idea of
the yazatas and the amas spentas at
least as separate entities is a later
invention of the religion that is not
present in the Goths themselves but that
of course isn't for us to decide here
what we should remember is that the
teachings of the religion including this
topic changed and evolved over time
making it hard to pin it down into a set
Doctrine so to say at least until much
later in history so in summary
Zoroastrianism at least in the avesta
scriptures teaches that there is a
cosmic drama created reality is a
vertical dualism divided between the two
forces on the one hand there is Asha
ruled over by the one good God Aura
Mazda and represented by his amesa
spentas and the various yadas and on the
other hand there is duj deception ruled
over by angrau and represented by him
and the other evil gods or Spirit refer
to as Davis the role of the human being
is to worship hurda and to become an
ashaan one who follows and spreads Asha
through ritual action and adhering to
the principles of good thoughts good
words and Good Deeds by doing so we are
gradually removing the stain of darkness
and evil from the world until we reach
fresh K when the world will once again
be perfect and where human beings will
be resurrected judged based on their
actions and then spend the rest of
Eternity in either pain or pleasure this
in essence with some clarifications and
additions from later institutionalized
theology can be seen as what Jenny Ross
refers to as the aveston world view
which lies at the center of zor
[Music]
asianism
zarathustra the probable author of The
gotha and the founder of zor asianism
proved to be a very influential figure
in the history of religion and
philosophy perhaps one of the most
significant in all of
history but during his lifetime this
wasn't necessarily the case at all we
find references in the Goths to the idea
that he was shunned and rejected by
people of Eastern Iran as he traveled
around but he did find one supporter in
the ruler vaspa and his Queen huta who
became his patrons and seem to have
adapted his religious reform whatever
was the case when other historical
records start showing up around a
millennium later after zarra lived it
becomes clear that his writings and
teachings had become very widespread
across greater Iran while we should be
careful to think about it as a unified
quote unquote religion as we think of it
today it's clear that some form of
developing Zoroastrianism was being
practiced by a large swath of the
Iranian population and would become
Central to the great Persian or Iranian
Empires such as the AIDS the parthians
and the cenans so to move on
chronologically then let's talk about
the famous Persian Empire the aits did
the aits practice
Zoroastrianism well the short answer is
yes we have to remember and I hammer
this down so much because it is
important to remember that sanism was
always evolving and changing and at this
relatively early stage we can't think of
Zoran ISM as a institutionalized
religion with clearly delineated
doctrines and borders but when we look
at the sources both internal ones such
as documents or Rock inscriptions as
well as outside sources such as from the
Greeks we can clearly see that the
accumed rulers adhere to a version of
that avestan world view that we
mentioned earlier many names of Royals
and officials carry names related to zor
asran scriptures and ideas and the
Emperors like Darius saw themselves as
playing an important role in this Cosmic
drama of representing the wisdom and and
authority of Aura Mazda and Asha on
Earth against its enemies in the
inscription at piston Darius the first
makes clear his Devotion to the God and
what this means quote by the grace of
Aura Mazda am I King ahura Mazda has
granted me the kingdom and quote a great
God is Aura Mazda who created this
excellent thing which is seen who
created happiness for man who set wisdom
and capability down upon King Darius
King Darius says by the grace of a hurda
I am of such a sort I a friend of the
right of wrong I am not a friend it is
not my wish that the weak should have
harmed done him by the strong nor is it
my wish that the strong should have harm
done him by the weak the right that is
my desire to the man who is a follower
of the lie I am no friend in other words
he's clearly placing himself with within
the aveston worldview and ethical
framework and this can be said to be
true generally for the
AIT in fact we see in the accumulated
period a few of the most prominent
features of zor astranis for the first
time so what did zor arism actually look
like on the ground during this period
well if you're looking for a neat and
simple to grasp answer you won't find it
here in general it seems that Zoran
worship for the most part took place
outside rather than in temples or other
dedicated buildings worship was
according to the Greek historian
Herodotus directed at certain natural
elements such as fire water and wind and
rituals could be performed on
mountaintops or other places in nature
as we saw ahura Mazda was still seen as
the high God who creates and sustains
the universe but Worship On The Ground
often focused on these other forces in
the form of amas spentas or yazatas the
Divine beings worthy of worship and who
were associated with natural phenomena
as you probably know one of the things
most strongly associated with zor
asianism is a reverence for fire and
this starts to become visible for the
first time here in the AED period where
fire along with water seems to have been
a particularly strong focus of
reverence fire along with running water
was seen as pure and represented the
light of Aura Mazda and Asha a a pure
expression of that good aspect of the
world that we are all to aim for in our
Lives Many including later Muslim
critics have often called zor asrian
fire worshippers in a derogatory way but
this thus needs to be clarified and
nuanced the fire is turned to as a
symbol an expression of light of
goodness and by extension of huram Mazda
while we don't find any examples of fire
temples in this period which would
become so prominent in later periods
there are examples of sacred fires that
were kept perpetually burning as an
important part of ritual or Worship in
some way indeed on Rock carvings one of
the most prominent themes is often a
three-part image of the king standing in
front of a burning fire Altar and above
both of them is the famous figure called
the fravashi which we'll return to later
in other words two of the most prominent
and famous symbols of Zoran ISM have
thus emerged and this seems to have
pointed to a kind of three-part uh
vision of authority in the world right
the king represents auram Asda in the
world his authority and and the the sort
of spreading of of Asha in the world the
fire also represents Divinity and light
and goodness and Asha in some way and
then the fravashi above uh also has a
very
significant meaning in symbolism again
which we will return to later because
it's pretty complicated sometimes it's
thought to represent the Hamas himself
but this isn't entirely sure uh but
these these three sort of symbols were
very important at this time and
particularly the latter two the fire and
the fravashi has remained sort of key
symbols for the religion till this very
day we are pretty sure that fire served
a ritual function already at this time
because there are mentions of something
called ataka or guardians of fire as
some kind of important functionaries in
the religion in general it is also in
the a period that we also see the
appearance of the main religious Experts
of Zoran ISM what we could call the um
the zorian priests which are called
Magi these Magi would become very famous
across the ancient world and among other
things they probably show up in the
gospel of Matthew as the three Magi or
wise men that bring gifts to baby Jesus
it is also from the word Magi that we
get terms like magic as these figures
became Associated outside of Iran with
things like astrology and different
kinds of you know what we would refer to
as magic even if this wasn't always
necessarily an accurate Association but
the appearance of the Magi tell us some
important things we mention that at
least in the early acced period worship
took place outside and was directed at
Natural Forces and the yazatas that were
associated with them well these yadas or
Divine beings really was a key aspect of
religious practice in this period Fire
and Water were important point of
reverence and these forces were
associated with particular Divine beings
and the two most popular in this period
were Mithra and anahita Mithra was
associated with the sun and thus to some
degree with fire even though fire often
had
a symbolized something even higher than
any of the individual yazatas but still
uh mythra was important and anahita was
a yaada that was primarily associated
with water the of these two Divine
figures especially in the later ained
period became very prominent and there
even started appearing temples dedicated
to them where the Magi would work as
functionaries in these temples the
Persians had been famous from outside as
having a religion that didn't have any
images auram Mazda was never depicted
unless the fashi was supposed to
symbolize him and other forces were
often rather Associated as we said with
natural forces or abstract Concepts
rather than images or or statues and
things like this but in this later
period of the accumulate Empire um
perhaps because of influence from the
outside such as from Greece or Babylon
maybe we do start to see images of the
yazatas in these temples too not to
mention the fact that when the Persian
Emperors conquered new territories such
as Egypt they sometimes adopted worship
of the local gods in these regions
too was this a political move for sure
but it also shows that quote unquote zor
actionism in this period was quite
complicated and chaotic and it didn't
really have the defined borders that it
would gain much later in history even
you know even if the rulers and
population of Iran generally held to the
so-called aveston worldview and some of
the basics of the avestan teachings this
is still true to some degree so then did
the aits practice zor asianism again the
short answer is yes but as I hopefully
shown there's significant amount of
nuance and complexity to be added to
that answer if we want to understand the
situation more properly but with that
said this is of course a very important
period for The Wider development of
Zoran however the azas or hurda andu
were supposed to be interpreted in the
gotha and the older text at this point
it becomes pretty clear that they are
viewed as akin to what we could call
gods or Spirits in a theological sense
and by this time it appears that the
very strong dualistic worldview had been
firmly established as we can see from
outside sources writing about the
religion of the Persians even Aristotle
himself describes the zoroastrian
dualistic doctrines according to
diogenes lures in the lives of the
philosophers he says quote Aristotle in
the first book of his work on philosophy
says that the Magi are more ancient than
the calans and that they have two
principles a good spirit and an evil
spirit the former is called Zeus and
orases azda the latter Hades and adanus
and Zoran ISM continued to play a role
even after the fall of the AIDS to
Alexander the Great and during the later
parthan Empire which lasted between 247
BC to around 224 ad during the later
cenan Empire this period the parthians
was often seen as one where the practice
and devotion of
zismo or that it stagnated until they so
the cenans sort of revived it again and
brought it back to its former glory but
looking at the historical record this
doesn't seem entirely true the parthan
period did see a lot of contact with
cultures outside Iran not least the
helenic world as well as India and
religious practice including Zoran ISM
was impacted by this environment in
different ways for example The increased
contact with religious Traditions from
Greece and you know things like Buddhism
in India might be one of the reasons
that we seem to see an increase in
things like uh images and icons of the
yadas as a focus of worship both the
Greeks and the Indians love to depict
their deities with images of different
sorts whereas the earlier zor Asian
practice had been without images and a
focus on worshiping outside and even
though as we saw we do seem to find a
few examples of images in the uh in the
later acced period this seems to
flourish even more in the parthan age
very significantly it is also During the
parthan period that we see the emergence
of fire temples ataska sometimes large
complexes dedicated to Fire and Magi or
priests that would tend to the fire as
well as make offerings to it including
animal sacrifice during the very
important yasna liturgy so in the
parthian period aside from Individual
practices the religious cult was focused
on two kinds of sacred buildings the
fire temples and the individual temples
dedicated to yazatas which would often
include images as we saw we should also
mention that during the parthan period
an attempt seems to have been made to
write down and preserve the old
scriptures of the avesta which had been
scattered and the uh oral tradition
taking a hit with the invasion of
Alexander of course this collection and
writing down of scripture and its
exegesis is attributed to the reign of
vak the Ashan or vases who lived between
who ruled between 51 to 78 ad but this
process of canonizing zor asrian
scriptures and creating something close
to an quote unquote Orthodoxy clearly
defining the religion and its principles
really started most properly to happen
under the cenans who ruled Iran between
around 224 to 652 ad it was during the
cenan dynasty that Zoroastrianism
reached the peak of its power and
prestige in a way because it is here
that the religious experts and Kings put
a huge emphasis on establishing a strong
zoroastrian religion that can stand up
against its rivals in the region and
serve as a solid foundation for the
Empire to fully grasp what is happening
here we need to consider the
context by the time these cenans came to
power some significant things had
happened in the Middle East which shaped
its religious and philosophical
landscape not least of course the birth
and increasing popularity of Rel
religions like Christianity and manism
religions that are heavily scriptural in
nature and with a very clear delimited
set of doctrines and practices and
Orthodoxy based on those scriptures
although this is relative of course
since you know Christianity at this time
was also incredibly diverse with many
different schools and with different
scriptures and interpretations of
scriptures but in general um the zor
asrian and the cenans were faced with an
enemy and with with other religions that
were very
heavily scriptural and with a very sort
of clear again relatively Orthodoxy and
beliefs based on those scriptures and
especially after the events of the 4th
Century with Christianity suddenly being
the state religion of the Roman Empire
who of course were the cenan's perhaps
foremost geopolitical enemy this of
course had a major impact on the Zoran
self-image being challenged
intellectually by these scriptural
religions zoroastrians realized that
they needed to clearly establish a set
Cannon of scripture and to collect those
scriptures in writing which they did the
religious experts and Priests of the
religion the Magi were also given an
increasingly High status at this time in
this period the high ranking religious
clergy were often known as a morbid the
fire temples became wealthy Institutions
and the religious clergy were very close
to the king and his court thus playing a
role in politics too and this can be
compared to the increasingly important
role of Bishops in the the Roman Empire
some of the highest ranking people of
the clergy the high priest or moad and
moad the priest of priests became famous
in their own right as very powerful men
with significant power such as kir and
adorad connected to all of this there
was also a concerted effort to more
clearly delineate what the zoroastrian
Orthodoxy was as we have seen zor
asianism historically while retaining
some basic avestan features at their
core could be quite varied in different
ways but here in this period we see a
strong conscious effort of getting rid
of heterodoxy and preced heresy for
instance the cenans authorized what
basically amounts to a kind of
iconoclasm all images of the azadas that
were found in temples around the region
were destroyed and instead were replaced
by fire altars so the temples to the
azadas were kept intact but the images
themselves were replaced by fires fire
and fire temples became the main Center
and focus of worship to the cenans with
the symbolic function of the fire we
talked about before being kept in mind
of course similarly there had appeared
at this time certain um interpretations
of zoroastrian doctrine that were deemed
heretical and were thus also
counteracted this includes what is known
as zurvanism where the concept of zervan
or time was seen as the highest
principle in
reality Aura Mazda and angra in this
system being two equal beings being born
from Zoran as sort of Sons of Zoran
there was also mazdaism which some have
compared to a kind of Quasi communist
social movement within the religion now
both of these movements zervan ISM and
mazdaism are so fascinating they
probably deserve episodes of their own
where you can focus more particularly on
them I have I have hopes to do those
episodes in the future but in any case
uh that were clear um s of attempts
clear efforts at this time to get rid of
all these What was seen as heretical
Cults heretical interpretations of the
religion and thereby through getting rid
of these heterodox views establish a
sort of unified true
Zoroastrianism and aside from the
collecting and canonization of the
Sacred avestin scripture this was also
done through new original texts and
scriptures that clarify the doctrines
and interpretations of Zionism in sort
of according to this uh Orthodoxy so to
say these new scriptures were all
written in the language known as middle
Persian so this is a further development
of the old language so um prob it'll
probably be good to to put up on the
screen a kind of um uh chronology of of
language so the Persian language is
divided into these different periods we
have old aveston which is the oldest
again we said this is between May 1500
to th000 BC this is the very earliest
Zoran scriptures like the Goths for
instance are written in this language
then we have the young aveston so from
thousand to 500 BC uh also some of the
most significant scriptures the avestan
scripture are in this period and written
in this evolution of the language then
from you know 500 from the AED period we
have what is known as old Persian again
a further development of this language
uh which is then replaced in in this
period in the 80s what is known as
middle
Persian uh for the sort of San period
and then from you know usually a good
Divi dividing Point here is f Do's
shaame which was written I think in the
11th century that's the start of new
Persian which is basically the language
that is still spoken you know the
official Persian in in in Iran today
right it comes so that is the chronology
of the different languages at this point
we're talking about new scriptures
written during the San Empire which
would have been written in Middle
Persian this includes the very important
Works called the bundan and the Denard
although at least part of these books
May originate in the early Islamic
period much of the details and
interpretations that we know about
cosmology and the great um Cosmic drama
that we talked about earlier is greatly
dependent on these middle Persian texts
in particular thus serving as key
sources for Zoran Doctrine despite being
such late compositions in other words
even though the religion had technically
existed for thousands of years before
this it is in this period that it
becomes more clearly uh defined codified
and
institutionalized probably as a classic
example of defining oneself in
opposition to the other because at this
time again we see the emergence and
prominence of many of these other
religions both inside and outside Iran
such as Christianity uh often also in
the case of Christianity as the very
religion of the political enemy and so
there is an effort to sort of Define
more clearly what zor what zor aism is
supposed to be in opposition to the
other right these other movements and
and religions and indeed while the level
of Tolerance varied from ruler to ruler
this is also a period when we often see
the oppression of religious minorities
such as Christians Buddhists and Hindus
on part of these Zoran clergy and
royalty critique was aimed at these
other religions as quote blind and
deceived by the deavas or ariman or
anamu and we see cases where the temples
and Idols of other religious groups such
as Buddhists Hindus and others were
destroyed for example the famous high
priest kerid that we mentioned earlier
says in an inscription that quote while
Adan and the deavas were punished and
rebuked and the teachings of adaman and
the deavas departed from the Empire and
were abandoned and Jews shamans brahans
nazarians Christians makak and zandik in
the Empire were smitten and destruction
of idols and scattering of the stores of
the Davis and God's seats and nests were
abandoned and in Kingdom after Kingdom
and place after Place many Divine
services in magnificence and many vahan
fires were established and many Magi
became happy and prosperous and many
fires in Magi were imperially installed
but we should of course remember that
this attitude wasn't true across the
board many rulers of the cenan empire
were quite tolerant of different groups
living in their Realms too
and looking more broadly the Persian
rulers especially those of the a dynasty
such as Cyrus the Great were generally
known across the board as tolerant
merciful and wise so we should see these
things more as signs of the times rather
than as an inherent aspect of the
religion itself religions as we know are
always what its practitioners make them
out to be and thus change and evolve
depending on how it is performed in
different times and places no one form
being more sh than any other at least
from a neutral academic standpoint
whatever the case this dominance of zor
asianism was to become significantly
altered with one of the most dramatic
events of late Antiquity or early Middle
Ages namely of course the Arab conquest
at the Advent of
[Music]
Islam
it was with the sudden invasions of the
Arab armies beginning in the 630s which
were very successful partly because of
the weakened sesanian Army after long
periods of war with the byzantines that
the landscape of Greater Iran and
Central Asia was to change change
forever but this topic is often over
sensationalized too and from both fronts
on the one hand you have people saying
that the Muslims completely decimated
the zoroastrian population forcing them
to convert or die and destroying nearly
all the fire temples and zor aan
buildings on the other hand you have
people saying that the Arab conquests
and Islamic takeover were completely
without any such violence or destruction
at all and of course neither of these
two extremes are true generally after
the conquest the zor Asians were
considered among the so-called people of
the book theab and were obliged to pay
the jazia tax just like Christians Jews
and other groups this meant that they
fell under the category of dii and they
and their sacred places including
temples were technically protected under
Islamic law in theory as long as you pay
the tax you were exempt from military
service and were equal to Muslims in
society of course in actual practice and
reality things were often quite
different but it is true that generally
during the omay caliphate the Zoran
population continued to flourish and
those that had been in power previously
were kept in their positions only now of
course under the higher authority of the
caleff forced conversions didn't really
happen as the Umayyads had a policy of
basically not wanting any non-arabs to
convert to Islam for various reasons but
with the Advent of the abasa dynasty
things started to change a little bit
and especially from the rule of the kff
alut and forward more strict rules
regarding the status of demies were
enforced in the Empire so in this period
several fire temples were destroyed or
converted to mosques and many other such
things and even though the treatment of
demies waxed and waned and changed
depending on who was in power and in
what period groups like zoroastrians
were to some degree always second class
citizens and had to withstand oppression
from time to time for these reasons many
people did start converting to Islam
making the zor asrian population dwindle
more and more but they did remain a
significant presence for a long time
until at least the invasion of the
Mongol armies and this decimated much of
the zoroastrian world that remained at
that time so we should recognize that
history is less black and white that we
are sometimes taught zor Asians remained
in the region and were allowed to
continue worshiping for the most part
but at the same time there is no denying
that there were periods of Oppression
and general second class treatment of
the zorian under the um many of the
Islamic dynasties so much so at least
that many chose to either convert to
Islam or to move elsewhere basically
most of them going to India and would
then make up the Pary Community which
still stands today but many zor asrian
remained in Iran too and went through
periods of persecution on the savits as
well as more positive periods such as
during the late 19th to 20th century
centries the pares in India are very
significant um they seem to have
established themselves at a very early
date um some say that the the the pares
sort of fled or immigrated from Iran
sometime in the eth or 9th centuries and
then they have established themselves as
a very prominent zor aan Community all
the way until today um now because they
have uh been in India over all these
centuries they of course developed
unique practices because of that region
and because of that sort of um at least
imp period lack of contact with their
Zoran kin in Iran uh and and today
actually the pares are the majority
Community it's the largest community of
zorian in the world um in some periods
they've also been seen even by the
Iranians orians as a kind of the
Guardians of the true faith and many
priests from Iran sort of traveled to
India to learn from the pares because
they had uh preserved
many of these scriptures and traditions
to a larger degree than had been
possible in Iran right so the pares are
really really important and they kind of
really deserve an episode of their own
too uh you know I make my my mention
here about them more brief than it
perhaps should be but you know I you
know keep in mind the pares are very
important for this story uh as they have
have been the the most you know in terms
of population the the most significant
the most populous Zoran Community for
you know centuries at this point so now
that we have a basic understanding of
the teachings and uh cosmology of of zor
aism as well as a good understanding of
the basic chronology so where it
originated and how it has developed over
the different periods and Empires and
and so on across history now we can sort
of start to dive into the actual
practices of zor asianism so what does
zor asianism look like to a regular
person how is this religion practiced on
a day-to-day basis well we should first
look at one of the most longlasting
aspects of Zoran ISM which is the
Liturgy known as the yasna we mentioned
this briefly in the beginning of the
episode this is a rather complex ritual
liturgy performed by priests daily this
is always in the morning and can take
several hours the yasna Liturgy take
place in the fire temple and involves
the preparation of the Sacred drink
known as haa and in ancient times at
least also involved animal
sacrifice today this latter aspect is
represented only by the clarified butter
that is consumed with bread which will
also involves things like water and a
focus on Purity much like you know the
rest of zor asianism but one of the main
aspects of the Liturgy involves reciting
the hymns and scriptures that make up
the yasna in terms of you know the yasna
as a collection of lurgical script
scriptures so the yasna is a ritual that
is performed daily by the priest but the
the word yasna is also used for the the
recitations the scriptures that is
resided uh that is resided during this
ritual the yasna in total consists of 72
sections with varying types of styles it
is for example in this yasna collection
that we find the five goth those
earliest writings attributed to zarra as
well as other hym the the Ys and other
early Zoran compositions many of which
were probably preserved because of its
use in this daily yasna liturgy so we
probably wouldn't have the oh I
shouldn't say probably but it's it's
it's possible that we wouldn't have the
Goths that they would have survived if
they weren't used in this very important
ritual that is probably a key reason why
they were preserved for so long after
all these sections are recited with the
actions associated with them the Liturgy
ends with a quote offering to the waters
this ritual has been very important for
the zoroastrian world view it is
believed that this is one of the most
effective and important ways that we
humans strengthen Asha and help it
become Victorious over the darkness in
the world as for regular lay people zor
aism involves daily prayers to be
precise there are five daily prayers to
be performed over the course of the day
the scholar Mary boy describes the
prayer like this quote First the
believer prepares himself by washing the
dust from face hands and feet then
untying the sacred cord he stands with
it held in both hands before him upright
in the presence of his maker his eyes on
the symbol of righteousness fire then he
prays to auram Mazda execrator flicking
the ends of the cord contemptuously as
he does so and re ties the cord while
still praying the whole observance takes
only a few minutes but its regular
repetition is a religious exercise of
the highest value constituting both a
steady discipline and a regular avowal
of the fundamental tenants of the
faith as you can see fire plays an
important role not just in the temple
but for the individual practitioners as
well and the chord that she mentioned is
also a very important part of zorian
practice this is known as a Kushi and
it's a core that is worn around the
waist by all invested or um initiated
zor asan this initiation ceremony that
zor aans go through usually takes place
for kids at age 15 the Kushi is made of
72 threads representing these 72
sections of the yasna Liturgy that I
mentioned earlier another key aspect of
Zoran practice is the seasonal festivals
that take place annually the main ones
are seven in number six of them
collectively being known as
ganar and they are and excuse the
pronunciation here may Zaya mids spring
my Shima Midsummer PTI shahia bringing
in the corn AA the homecoming Maya
midwinter and Hamas path media which has
unknown meaning as you can tell with the
exception of the last one all these
festivals celebrate the different
seasons and things like Harvest they
also represent the six amesa spentas a
side from the seventh spent Manu which
is identical to hamda as we said before
the sixth of the one mention the last
one is not directly connected to the
calendar year but is rather a
celebration of the so-called
fravashis so finally then we have to
tackle this topic what is a
fravashi honestly this is one of the
more complex and difficult Concepts in
this religious system because it's kind
of unlike anything we recognize from
other religions the fravashi is like the
high self of a human being so before we
are born we sort of live with auram Asda
in his world as fravashi almost like
Divine being ourselves but when we are
born our soul becomes separated from the
fashi and travels down to this world to
gain experience and knowledge and to
help strengthen Asha for example but we
are still in contact so to say with our
fravashi our higher self and once we die
we will reunite with it and the
fravashis became an important part of
the religion often being revered or even
worshiped in themselves particularly
fravashis of Asians or important people
and ancestors of the past and that
perhaps most common symbol for
Zoroastrianism the winged being that we
find in so many ancient inscriptions and
thumbnails for YouTube videos is at
least according to most a
fravashi some have believed that it is a
depiction of Aura Mazda but this seems
unlikely given the fact that auram Mazda
is very rarely depicted in image so the
jury seems to be out still on exactly
what the symbol is and it might have
symbolized different things in different
periods for example but mostly it is
known as a fravashi in any case the
seventh yearly Festival stands apart
from the others in some way it doesn't
represent a single Amisha spenta but
represents fire itself that Force which
at least symbolically lies at the core
of all the amas spentas being their
quote pervasive life force this Festival
of fire which also often serves as the
Iranian New Year is known as noru
literally meaning new day noru takes
place every year on the Spring Equinox
and appears to have been in a way the
most important and popular of the
festivals indeed even though zor
asianism hasn't been the majority
religion in Iran for many centuries the
celebration of noru is still very preva
vent among its people both in the region
and in diaspora communities and for
different religious denominations in the
region
too there are elaborate ways of
practicing this festival and still
serves as an important day for Iranian
and Central Asian people around the
world lastly another famous aspect of
zor asrian practice that we should
mention involves their burial Customs if
you remember when we talked about fire
we said that this natural element is
seen as pure and thus representing light
and goodness and there has been a huge
emphasis on not polluting things like
fire and water in any way for this
reason things like Cremation of dead
bodies has been completely out of the
question for Zoran across history as
that would of course pollute the pure
fire with dead human flesh and death of
course being one of the main symbols and
results of duj and anru of evil and and
this decay in the world instead the
Zoran custom has been what is known as a
sky burial there often existed dedicated
places known as dma or towers of Silence
these were often located far away from
humans and pure things like fire and
water and dead bodies would be taken
here they would be left out in the open
for vultures to consume the
carcass when this process was over the
bones were sometimes collected and then
put in a sort proper grave the reasoning
for this as we said is that dead human
bodies are impure they are a part of the
ug aspect of the world and one can thus
not let that come into contact with pure
things such as water fire and even Earth
making any other kind of burial can of
inappropriate this practice and the
towers of Silence has indeed become one
of the most famous aspects of zor
asianism to The Wider public with that
said it's also true that many today many
zor aans especially in diaspora
communities will bury their dead in
cemeteries uh and and you know there's
probably interesting uh discussion or or
video to be made about the internal uh
conversations about those cancer
practices how that is Justified how one
adapts to new situations in diaspora
communities for example but you know
just putting that out there that many of
these Customs that were maybe prevalent
in in ancient times aren't always
necessarily um practiced by Zoran today
so that is a general overview of zor
asianism its teachings history and
practices as you can tell this is a deep
and complex religion that really needs a
lot more time to cover fully or properly
but I hope that this has given you a
better understanding of the tradition
and maybe inspired you to do further
research on your own now one of the most
widely discussed aspects of the zorian
legacy is of course its relationship
with the other religions particularly
the abrahamic ones indeed Zoroastrianism
is probably one of the most important
and influential ual religions in history
and sometimes
indirectly I'm sure many of you as I've
gone through their teachings have
recognized many aspects from religions
that are more popular today and this is
an important and significant point the
general dualistic cosmology with a clear
idea of good versus evil represented by
a good God and His lower Divine beings
on the one hand and an evil demon and
his minions on the other of course
reminds us a lot about the theologies of
religions like
Christianity and Islam and their
concepts of God and angels versus the
devil and his demons furthermore the
eschatological teachings about a final
judgment where the dead will be
resurrected and based on their actions
in life will be sent to either a
paradisal life or an eternity of Agony
this is essentially identical to
teachings of Christianity at least parts
of Judaism and in Islam even the
particular teachings about the bridge
that must be crossed which evil people
becomes thin like a blades Edge and
causing them to fall down into hell we
find almost direct parallel here in
Islamic lore so what is going on here
well we should remember that zor
asianism was a major and important
religion in the ancient world
represented by one of the largest
empires in history During the period of
the Babylonian exile and afterwards the
Jews were often in direct contact with
zor Asians and generally seems to have
quite liked them the Bible basically has
nothing but good things to say about the
aimit even calling Cyrus the Great
Messiah for allowing the Jews to return
to Judea and indeed it is after and
during this period of direct contact
that we see Israelite literature such as
that of apocalypticism where many of
these eschatological and um theological
ideas appear for the first time
including the concept of Satan or the
devil as well as the day of judgment and
Heaven and Hell it is thus quite
probable that zor arism in some way had
a direct impact and influence on these
major religions of the world and their
teachings even aspects like the seant
the sort of Savior figure in zor aism
there's actually multiple seant usually
so it's not like there's just one Savor
figure but this idea of a Savor figure
that will come um partly at the end of
time to to instigate or to be part of
this um re invigorating of the world
making it good again of course has been
used by many Christians as being a kind
of Prophecy uh that um that talks about
the coming of Jesus and that this is
sort of a a Messianic Concept in some
way that also sort of made its way into
Judaism and Christianity uh so there's a
lot of these different concepts that are
very similar to the abrahamic uh
Traditions but we should also remember
that things aren't black and white and
that this isn't a one-way Street Zoro
asan in Antiquity lived in close
proximity with Christians Jews mandans
helin and many others and it's quite
likely that just as zor asianism
influenced them so they also influenced
zor aism in turn impacting the way that
that religion was shaped especially in
periods like during the parean and
cilian
Empires however we choose to look at it
there's no denying that zor aism plays a
very important role in the history of
religion and
philosophy it serves as one of the
oldest surviving religious traditions in
the world and one that has changed and
evolved over the Millennia from the
gotha of zarathustra some of the oldest
religious literature in the world all
the way until today zoroastrians have
shaped our world they still make up a
significant Community even if they
aren't as prominent as they used to be
the largest community today are again
the pares living in India but there are
also significant communities in Iran in
Europe and in North America estimates
have shown that there are around 100,000
zor asan in the world today but the
actual numbers are often thought to be
significantly higher I hope this has
been an interesting and educational
hopefully entertaining episode on zor
rism if you want more content like this
then you can uh subscribe to the channel
check out my other stuff uh leave a
comment let me know what you think uh as
always of course I would like to extend
a special thank you to all my patrons
who support the channel monetarily and
keep the channel going none of this
would be possible without you of course
so thank you all so much uh patreon is
again the best way to support this
channel uh so I would highly appreciate
if anyone else wanted to become a patron
2o so I will leave links to that in the
description um you can find me on my
socials if you're interested on
Instagram and Tik Tok and so on I also
of course have my other channel FIP Palm
where I post mostly music and music
content so check that out if you're
interested too for now thank you all so
much for watching for uh staying
passionate about learning new things um
hope to see you um soon again with more
content similar to this and I'll see you
next
[Music]
time